Speaker 1: I absolutely love this next story.
But it also makes me a little bit depressed
over how easy it is when your audience is
ignorant to basic facts.
It's so easy to convince your audience of
absolute nonsense.
As we reported yesterday, one of the things
that President Joe Biden did at last night's
speech before a joint session of Congress
was to propose and outline his one point eight
dollars billion package that includes paid
family leave, child care, universal pre-K,
community college and many other things.
This is very much a sort of FDR like package
meant to stimulate the economy by putting
the middle class into a more stable economic
position.
It's not really controversial, globally speaking,
historically speaking, but I guess to the
American right wing, it is absolute insanity,
reminiscent of Bernie Sanders is democratic
socialism or something.
Here are the Fox and Friends hosts yesterday
morning reacting incredulously.
They're beside themselves because of Joe Biden's
proposal, saying, hey, we elected Bernie,
not Joe Biden.
Of course, the implication being, Bernie,
the socialist Biden is actually Bernie.
Biden is really a socialist.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Biden essentially is, as Julian
said, going to take a victory lap of what
he's been able to accomplish so far.
Some of the things he promised on the campaign
trail that are going to be missing from his
speech tonight, missing lower prescription
drug prices, not going to be talking about
that, not going to be talking about expanding
Medicare eligibility.
And this is really important.
I know a lot of you watching have been curious
about the estate tax.
He will not be including that campaign plan
to raise the estate tax from forty to forty
five percent or lower the exemption from 11
million to three point five million.
Because there are a lot of people, particularly
family farm owners, were very concerned about
that particular position.
If it went in, they would be sunk.
Yeah, he he'll get around to it.
Trust me, America, you elected Bernie Sanders.
You just didn't know it.
Speaker 1: So this is a coded way of saying
Biden is a socialist because he wants to do
paid family leave.
Biden is Bernie.
Bernie is a socialist America.
You now have a socialist president.
One reaction for many people to this clip
was, I wish we had elected Bernie.
But a more kind of on this planet reaction
is that Joe Biden's proposal is, number one,
quite moderate by global standards.
No.
Two, targeted based on need.
And number three, really unlikely to pass
as proposed.
I've said this before.
I don't you know, people sometimes get mad.
They say, David, by saying that you're making
it less likely to pass as proposed.
No.
What you hear from a president during a State
of the Union or State of the Union like speech
is the framework.
It's sort of like when the White House releases
a budget.
The White House budget is a political document.
Biden's original proposal is a political proposal.
It then gets negotiated.
So it's not even like it's going to pass the
way it's actually been proposed.
For an example, I'm in a bunch of financial
planning type circles, forums, newsletters
and Subrata.
It's for the last two weeks, the topic that
keeps coming up among some of the highest
income people in these groups is what are
you doing based on Joe Biden wanting to double
the capital gains tax rate?
The most sensible and the most common answer
has been, I'm doing nothing yet.
Why?
Well, Joe Biden is now laying out what he
wants.
That will be subject to negotiation.
It will almost certainly be watered down.
If it passes, it might be retroactive to twenty
twenty one.
It might only.
Art in twenty twenty two, once we get there,
I can decide this is other people speaking,
do I take the gains on my stock and bonds
and pay the capital gains rate, or do I just
wait and do nothing and wait for a future
president to change the rate again and not
pay any of that capital gains rate?
The point is people are going nuts, as if
Biden's ideas are radical, but also as if
they're going to pass as proposed.
We're at step zero, point five.
Biden told told us what he wants.
And then, of course, there's this really weird,
weird thing where Brian Kilmeade is slamming
Biden for the things he is proposing, whereas
Steve Doocy is slamming Biden for the things
that Biden promised but are not part of the
proposal.
Steve Doocy there said, you know, Biden promised
to change the estate tax and he's not doing
it as part of this.
Shouldn't do.
C.B happy about that?
Fox News is part of the estate tax is a death
tax contingent.
He should be glad Biden is not proposing it,
at least for now.
But yet he says, oh, that Biden also is not
doing the things he promised to do.
Of course, the real answer is none of it is
about policy.
It's never been about policy, it's about posturing
to your audience, period.
Biden has proposed something.
Let's now see what the negotiation is like
and what gets to the floor of the House and
Senate and then whether it passes, deal with
these things one step
at
a time.